>>Teacher: All right, friends, who
wants to do the breathing technique?
>>Dr Darling-Hammond: One of the things
that actually improves the architecture
of the brain is movement and
physical activity. In this classroom,
you can really see the
mind-body connection
and how both the mindfulness activities
and the movement activities
allow children
to free their brains and
be prepared to learn.
>>Cynthia: Throughout the
morning, we'll either stop
and do a breathing technique,
some kind of mindfulness strategy,
or a movement break understanding
that, one, little kids can't attend
for that long, or be
still for that long. Two,
if we do have a certain percentage
of kids with toxic stress,
they have high amounts of
cortisol and the way to release
that is through physical movement.
>>Dr Cantor: Cortisol, and a fight
or flight reaction, will make it hard
to pay attention to learning.
Very often,
practices like movement breaks enable
children to get more self-regulated
and calmer, and therefore
open to a learning experience.
>>Teacher: Many teachers will lead
activities themselves. Some will project
images and using a person
onscreen who helps take kids
through a different movement activity.
>>Student: First we are
going to do the pretzel.
>>Falon: So they got to do the pretzel.
So they breath in, deep inhale, exhale,
deep inhale, exhale. Basically,
just to relax them, calm them down.
>>Student: Next we are going
to do the breathing ball.
>>Cynthia: Our PE teacher and
our yoga teacher that we contract
with have also taught the teachers
different strategies to use,
and so you'll see them
implementing that throughout the day.
>>Teacher: Sometimes you may feel
nervous, you may feel a little anxious,
you may not know what to do, but you can
always stop, take a deep breath, and...
>>Student: Relax.
>>Teacher: Relax.
>>Dr Cantor: This idea of children
sitting for long periods of time,
they aren't naturally wired to do that.
So rather than put them in a position
where they have to act out to
demonstrate that they need to be able
to move, building in movement
breaks means that they will get some
of the stress relief, some of the
energy release that they need in order
to be able to get calm again
and pay attention to learning.
>>Dr Darling-Hammond: In fact,
physical activity is equally important
for adolescents and adults
to keep the mind clear,
to relieve stress, to be ready to learn.